we're basically coming to terms with our
sins of the past yes slavery racism
anti-Semitism the list goes on and on
homophobe
but yet in the Far East or in Russia and
China and the mulas in Iran
um they're they're proud to be where
they're from but then let's go deeper
you don't think they've done stuff to be
ashamed of
how many tens of millions of Chinese
were killed under Mao how many tens of
millions of people were stuck in the
gulags
um with with
Stalin and Lenin yet they're still able
to be proud and not teach their kids to
be ashamed of the past Germany has how
many
um I mean you go to Auschwitz and you go
to Poland and they they have remembrance
of the Holocaust basically owning the
sins of the past yet still being proud
of their Heritage and their future why
can't we do both